hi i'm ryan wright hello and i'm jerry
welcome to reasons to see where normally
we would give you reasons to see and
normally we would give you reasons not
to see
whatever movie we're reviewing but today
we're not going to be reviewing a movie
no
uh we're going to be talking about a
movie that hasn't come out yet
that we have not seen yeah that there's
only a trailer for
and we're gonna talk about that trailer
want to tell you our anticipation
feelings
and we're shooting this after we've
already shot most of the video
it's good [ __ ] it's like the best [ __ ]
it's like that [ __ ] when you get home
after a long day
oh yeah yeah and it's like you had to
but you couldn't for a while and then
like you couldn't fart because
everywhere you went it's quiet but there
was a [ __ ] ton of people anyway so it's
like yeah i can't even
fart it was the day you had to go to
five libraries
i know exactly that day may 19 2005
yeah right for some reason 2005 was a
very library every year in my life
like captain america the winter soldier
so we just watched the trailer for
captain america the winter soldier
captain phillips the winter soldier
the movie looks [ __ ] sweet dude
yeah it really does i mean this is the
first time i've seen that trailer and i
gotta tell you i'm more excited for this
than than the new thor
oh i'm way more excited for this than
than you thor like it's weird because i
wasn't a big fan of the first
i don't really like the first captain
america movie but the avengers really
made me like captain america a lot
and it's cool to see like how this one
takes place it doesn't feel like oh
they're advertising avengers 2.
it just takes place in in shield it
makes sense for captain america to be
there i don't really know the comics of
captain america but
to follow that storyline and then just
have you be part of that world again and
it looks like they're going for like a
much
darker tone you know the way to angry
sequel is going to get darker
i feel like the phrase going for a much
darker tone
comes up quite a lot yeah it's reboots
or sequels that's the new hollywood
drinking game whenever anybody says oh
the next one's gonna be even darker
you have to take a drink yeah how's thor
two it's gonna be in the dark world
winter you know it's darker out for
whatever reason i don't know lately i
haven't been as
like super psyched for big you know
blockbuster action movies but this
trailer as of right now
i'm actually anticipating this film you
know a lot of these big sequels like
i'm sort of like yeah i can wait this
looks pretty awesome and it seems like
well it's different from the original
one because you don't have that
old-timey production value
just from the looks of the trailer it
seems like it feels like a captain
america movie
influenced by the avengers but
still captain america in tone i really
feel like we're gonna
get a sense of like hardcore leadership
from this guy
which is what i want to feel from
captain america i didn't get that
feeling when i saw the first one so in
this one i really want to get that sense
of like first one he's becoming a leader
yeah and this one he's gonna be the
[ __ ] leader because he's like hey man
you can't just go
[ __ ] nuking [ __ ] because of what's
going on currently that's not freedom
he's gonna take a stand against nick
fury yeah the last stand
with the rock and johnny knoxville
no no last name
that was walking tall and my boy because
you pointed this out my boy anthony
mackie is in this which i'm excited oh
dude anthony mackie looked so
cool when he jumped off the ship and he
just started firing the guns what's his
name
is he falcon or i don't know he's like
he's a
yeah he has a name i don't pretend i
used to try to be like the guy who would
know stuff about comics but here's the
truth i
i don't know as much as i try to be the
cinematography looks
dope in this one it looks awesome you're
saying dope a lot lately yeah dope's my
new word yeah
dope is dope i ever smoked but uh yeah
the cinematography looks great i did not
know that robert redford was in this
i knew he was in it i heard he spoiled
something and i didn't read that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah because he hates marvel i
like the people that
read the caption robert redford spoil
something
and like contain spoilers and then they
click on it and read it and then they
get that
robert redford for ruining those part of
the movie when it was
the whole thing was about him spoiling
something i was just so impressed
with what we have in cinema today with
this marvel universe that's going on you
know to have like the agents of shield
show
like and work for my here i haven't seen
it yet but i hear it's pretty damn good
and then you got like all these
different movie
franchises that all come collectively
together in one franchise in itself
and you know what i mean it's so cool to
see that in cinema to like watch an iron
man movie and then watch a thor movie
but then know how they're linked it
feels like
different series of comics but in movie
form that's how comics work it's like
all the heroes have their own story
lines and and even
multiple story lines and then you have
them come together for whatever alliance
it's brought comics to life it really
has yeah and it's i think it's really
smart of marvel to do that because it's
you know you look at dc or some of the
other comic labels and it seems like
they're having trouble figuring this out
and marvel
at least you know say what you will
about whatever entries as
films but their system and their phases
and stuff
is really well thought out you know oh
yeah because it does really
done it's like the cinematic equivalent
of different
series of comics i just wish they could
get a hulk movie right
i want them to get one right where
everyone has an agreeance on i think the
hulk deserves
a movie and it's sad to know that
they're not really even
thinking about making one yeah i mean
they're continuing their their
you know really heavy hitting franchises
and now they're starting to introduce
new characters and stuff is nick fury
not a good person because i think that's
what these movies are trying to do with
nick fury is
just make him always suspiciously like
should we trust him
that's the thing about superheroes
though it's like you always got trust
issues because who can you trust
no one that's the thing that's why i
would never want to become that's
[ __ ] i would totally have to be a
supervisor
all right guys thanks for checking us
talking about captain america the winter
soldier
i'm sure you valued every second of it
why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and you
tell us what you think of captain
america the winter soldier
and then once you're done with that come
on over here click this button so you
can see more episodes of reasons to see
i'm gonna make this really quick because
not many of you are doing it follow us
on twitter and like us on facebook and
then once you're done with that
subscribe subscribe subscribe subscribe
i i think it's subscribe be a whole
sequence where the ship's getting taken
down too that looks like a cool fight
scene
yeah the way they set up the villain was
so [ __ ] cool because they they teased
him just enough
yeah and like just him capturing the
shield and it goes oh
captain america
this should be it this that should be
the last trailer